In the last few years,
Chile has become the Christiana Renaldo
last in America.
It was the country with the highest
growth,
had the most success and sticking with
our metaphor here,
it scored the most goals also for many
classical liberals,
Chile has been the benchmark for years
we can say they considered the Chilean
models something of a dream in a world
full of dark nightmares,
and it was true.
There were good reasons for celebration
Chile,
which ones was the poorest Spanish
country in Latin America became the
richest in the region.
It became the country with the highest
life expectancy in the country with the
best social services in the entire
region.
It is true that inequality is very high
in Chile,
but the entire population of Chile has
benefited from the prosperity that the
country has achieved over the past few
decades.
For the past 25 years,
the income of the poorest people in the
country has increased far more than the
income of the wealthiest people as their
purchasing power has grown six times
larger.
All of this compares very favorably to
other Latin American nations.
As an example,
in 1950,
the average income was around a third of
Venezuelan income in a manner of
speaking and Venezuelans were three
times richer.
A lot has changed since then and today.
Chileans are much richer than
Venezuelans.
They also have a longer life expectancy,
hla and lives in average of eight years,
more than a person born in Venezuela.
Okay.
Comparing Chile to Venezuela or
Argentina shore makes Chilean look good,
but when the comparison is made with
other more distant countries,
for example,
those in Asia,
the figures aren't nearly so nice and
further.
It seems as if the country has stopped
growing,
which is certainly well,
yes,
the Chilean slow down
last few years.
The optimism and success,
well,
it's come to an end in San Diego,
the capital of the country,
the displays of wealth and prosperity of
left making room instead for
demonstrations and protests,
anger and despair have taken over and
well,
it's only logical economic growth has
fallen for the last few years and in
2016,
unemployment increased while salaries
remains frozen.
Further,
the youth can't find jobs in both
investment and exports have fallen and
the thing is that things aren't looking
like they're going to get any better
anytime soon.
Twenty 16,
the Chilean economy grew by one point,
five percent.
Truly central banks forecast for 2017
are not a whole lot better.
Increasing to two percent from one
percent.
Just want me to all of the growth of the
last decades.
Three out of every four Chileans make
less than $700 a month,
so now you can probably understand their
anger.
These aren't the salaries that belonged
to a rich country,
so all in all,
the Chilean model seems to be failing
and there is one person who is
responsible for this slow down.
And that's Miquel Baca.
That's the current president of Chile.
Evolution of Bachelot Michelle
backlash was the president of Chile for
March,
2016,
March 2010,
but essentially a president can be
elected to two consecutive terms,
so bankers have to wait four years
before she could run again for Lamanita
the name of the presidential palace in
Chile.
Well,
after gaining the support of almost all
the left wing parties,
including the Socialist Party and the
Communist Party,
won the elections in November of 2013
and a few months later,
I'd been march of 2014,
she became the president of the Republic
of Chile again
in the second time back,
let decided to go through with reforms
which were much more aggressive than the
ones she came up with at the time
around.
Her first decision was to increase
taxation on companies by almost 40
percent.
Quite a dramatic move.
He did it by raising rates on profits
and also by eliminating a bonus,
which means companies could reduce
taxation if the profits were reinvested
in Chile.
Think about it.
That was all about reinvestment,
was actually a really reasonable
incentive.
A country like China,
which is far from being rich,
needs factories,
machines,
businesses,
technology and investments,
and this incentive encouraged the growth
of all of these things.
So the question is,
what's the point of publishing companies
providing this much needed investments?
And in addition to all of this taxation
on companies wasn't exactly low.
To begin with,
take a look at how things are now off
tobacco that has punished these
companies.
Chile has the second highest corporate
taxes in the world surpassed only by
Japan,
a much richer country with much larger
companies,
and would you like to know the
consequences of this measure?
Well,
investment has fallen by 30 percent
since backer lead came back to the
presidential palace and of course,
less investment means ness job's less
growth and therefore less tax revenue.
In other words,
they decided to eat the cake before they
could even bake us and weld.
That rarely works.
That is why there has been a clear
international tendency to reduce
taxation on companies over the last few
years.
Canada,
the UK and Ireland are some examples of
countries where corporate taxes has been
reduced.
The new president of France,
Emmanuel Macron,
has also promised to reduce taxes
well,
surely.
Well,
it's headed in the opposite direction,
but do wait a second here because well,
that's not the other two main reforms.
Bachelors is put through.
You have resulted in a very similar
outcome.
Labor reform as made recruitment more
expensive and has given more power to
trade unions.
Some,
I liked the sounds of this,
but it means more costs for companies
which when added to the increase on
taxation means there is even less
investments,
less competition and less exports.
Essentially.
All of this has caused,
well the whole lot of problems.
On the other hand,
tobacco ads tried to pass an ambitious
reform.
Do you turn the private college
education system into a public free of
charge service?
The problem is the visual politic view
of that.
This model is very expensive and some
say the solution to the problems of
education is to improve the quality of
the universities themselves instead of
making them into factories,
printing deployments.
But anyway,
the thing is back in that couldn't pass
this reform and in her attempt to do so,
she turns the whole education system
upside down.
For example,
she has reduced the amount of investment
that was plans to improve the quality of
these universities,
but okay,
well now you might be wondering,
well,
what are the citizens of Chile?
Think about all of this.
Well,
that's look closely.
Percent of Chileans believe that
Michelle Bachelet government must delay
or at least moderate some of the reforms
that have recently taken place in the
country,
especially educational reform.
It feels as if I was working towards an
ideological change rather than a formula
which could actually sold national
problems.
In fact,
all these reforms and the hostility
towards private corporations have led to
Chile to suffer the worst economic
period for decades as well.
Do you know who is most negatively
affected by the situation?
Well,
that's the poor and the working class
after all the wealthy already have a
good standard of living.
Okay.
The thing is,
backlit leaves the country with a crisis
with the growing public deficit,
with the highest public spending of the
last 26 years,
and frankly with the damage to economy.
But now that you know all of this,
you might be wondering,
well,
besides backlash,
one of the biggest weaknesses in Chile.
Well,
let's have a look.
Chili's.
Weaknesses,
yes.
The shelly doesn't like foreign
professionals.
It's a bit strange for a country like
Chile because they seem to have been
incapable of attracting foreign
professionals.
Immigration is only two percent,
and while that's a problem,
because it affects entrepreneurship,
innovation and trait,
why won't Chili grow?
Because it is full of Chileans.
Ricardo Hausmann,
director of the Center for International
Development of Harvard University.
Generally speaking,
foreign professionals tend to be more
entrepreneurial,
which helps the economy too diverse.
In Chile,
the rate of entrepreneurship among
immigrants is four times higher than
that among native Chileans.
The second problem is that the so called
social data is not working.
That is deceived.
There are new changes in the social
classes.
If you're born boy,
you die poor.
If you're born rich,
you'd die rich.
In fact,
the country is really controlled by
seven families whose wealth is
equivalent to 17 percent of the national
GDP.
This might seem unimportant,
but when the social ladder in
competition don't work,
it means the family name is more
important than talent and effort.
The opportunity costs for the country is
huge and these families usually have
quite special relationships with power.
Consider this
bachelet son was charged with corruption
and Ronica look,
which one of the most powerful men in
Chile and the owner of the Bank of Chile
was also involved in the scandal.
Yup.
Even the back of that name has been
spoiled with corruption.
Then there's the bureaucracy.
I'm sure you've heard that Chile is a
very free economy.
Well,
when you take a closer look,
you can see it's also very bureaucratic.
It has all kinds of regulations.
For instance,
Chiney can't import secondhand cars and
foreign workers don't have access to a
bank accounts so well.
It certainly seems as if it could be
more free.
Mark Twain said that all three kinds of
lies,
Damn lies and statistics.
The thing is initially,
well they probably have some of that
selections in the country will take
place on the 19th of November,
2017,
and one thing is for sure if Jenny wants
to go back to the good times,
they must change direction.
It's like,
well,
that's our opinion here,
official policy Polish.
Now.
We'd love to know what you think.
What is your opinion of backlash?
What do you think of the Chilean model?
Well,
please leave your answers in the
comments below and click like if you did
enjoy this video,
I would also like to take this time to
thank our friends at the reconsider
media podcast for providing some of the
voiceover vocals for this video and do
not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday,
and there's always.
I'll see you next [inaudible].